We'll now return to the questions that we
asked at the very beginning of this
lesson.
Starting from genomes, how can we
transform them into synteny blocks?
And the first thing I want you to learn is
the notation of genomic dot plot.
Let's arrange genome along x coordinate
and along y coordinate.
And let's represent
every k-mer that is shed at position x and
y in the
genome as a dot, a position with
coordinates x and y.
In this case, I show you genomic dot plot
for k-mer size equal to 3.
And it only consists of the diagonal in
the genomic dot plot.
Of course, diagonal is always present in
the genomic
dot plot because k-mers at the coordinate
x and x are always the same.
But here's the genomic dot plot for k=2,
and you can see that in
this case the number of dots increased as
compared to k=3.
For example these 4 dots correspond to
repeated occurrences of the 2-mer CT in
the genome.
So far, we talked about a genome
consisting
of one strand, but in reality of course
genome consists of 2 strands,
and therefore we should take care of both
identical and
reverse complementary k-mers while
representing genomic dot plots,
as shown here.
In this case, red points correspond to
identical k-mers, and blue points
correspond to
reverse complementary k-mers.
Now
this is how a genomic dot plot looks like
when we compare genome against itself.
But can we also construct genomic
dot plots when comparing two different
genomes?
And here's an example of comparing one
genome with another
one that is obtained from the first one by
a reversal.
And in this case, you can see that a
reversal corresponds
to the -45 degree diagonal formed by blue
points in this genomic dot plot.
Now, from
looking at the small string, let's now
construct genomic dot
plot for entire E. Coli
and Salmonella genomes.
And human eye immediately see synteny
blocks
in this genomic dot plot, they simply
correspond to various diagonals.
And we only pay attention to sufficiently
long diagonal, because small
diagonal, or small points, clusters of
points may represent noise in
this case.
So we see five synteny blocks, five
diagonal corresponding to a block marked
asa a, b, c, d and e,
and if we project these blocks on the
x axis we will get an arrangement of
synteny blocks in E. Coli.
And if we project them on the y-axis then
we'll get
an arrangement of synteny blocks in
salmonella.
And now we are ready to analyze the
2-break distance between these two genomes.
Therefore, construction of synteny blocks
essentially amount
to constructing diagonals in the genomic
dot plot.
And here is the finding synteny blocks
problem.
The input is the set of points in
genomic dot plots in 2D, and the output is
a set of diagonals in DotPlot representing
synteny blocks.
Does it make sense?
Of course it doesn't make sense.
Because I have not defined what diagonals.
Look at this genomic dot plot and you can
see the diagonals
are not perfect because there are many
insertions, deletions, mismatches and many
other artifacts, and therefore human eye
has the ability
to somehow process this genomic dot plot
into
five diagonals, but we really do not know
what our brain is doing while making this
transformation.
Can we come up with an algorithm for
constructing these diagonals?
Let's try.
Let's look at the genomic dot plot between
two different genomes that we constructed
before.
And let's represent every dot in the dot
plot as a node in the graph.
And we will form edges in this graph by
simply connecting closely located points.
For example, points that are located at a
distance less than maxDistance, where
maxDistance is a parameter.
What will happen?
We will connect certain points by edges,
and you can see from here
that diagonals actually correspond to
connected components in this graph.
Moreover, we probably should ignore very
small connected components.
For example, a component located in the
upper-right (upper-left to the viewer)
corner and low left corners (lower-right to the viewer),
but the three remaining
components should be accepted as synteny
blocks in our genome.
And therefore, I offer you the following
algorithm for solving the problem.
Let's form a graph whose node set is the
set of points in DotPlot, and
connect two nodes by an edge if the
corresponding nodes are located at close
distance from another.
The connected components in the resulting
graph define synteny block.
And afterwards, delete small synteny
blocks.
Of course this is not the only algorithm
that tries to model what the human eye is
doing, while clustering points in 2D, and
our brain is very good at clustering.
I can give you another algorithm, for
example this one that I call Amalgamate.
And it actually different, but it looks
like it's doing almost the same thing.
First step, define each point in DotPlot
as
a separate block and iteratively
amalgamate the resulting block.
How do we amalgamate the blocks?
We amalgamate two blocks and combine them
into a single block
if they contain two points that are
separated by small distance in
another genome, and as before delete small
synteny blocks.
So we have a problem and we have two
algorithms for solving it.
Which algorithm would you use?
Instead of answering this question, you
should
ask me what problem I actually want you
to solve, because I have never defined an
algorithmic problem that I want you to
solve.
You should have refused coming up with an
algorithm
before actually seeing the problem I want
to address.
Unfortunately, in bioinformatics, it's not
as simple.
I have been working on the problem of
synteny block generation for 10 years now,
and I failed to formulate this problem as
a rigorous algorithmic problem, and that's
why we
are at mercy of our intuition.
And some people may like Synteny algorithm
better.
Other people may like Amalgamate algorithm
How would we choose?
The choice should be done based on the
practical results.
And if you implement these algorithms and
run them, then you
see that synteny algorithm gives
a reasonable and biologically adequate
result.
But amalgamate algorithm, also, it looks
reasonable, it looks like it
models what human eye may be doing, gives
completely wrong results.
After developing the algorithm for
constructing
synteny blocks, we are now ready to
find out what are the synteny blocks
between human and mouse X chromosome.
And here's a genomic dot plot for the X
chromosome consisting of 25,000 dots.
We form a synteny graph on these 25,000
nodes.
And at this slide, you can see the resulting
connected components.
We further process of these connected
components and represent them
as a perfect +45 degree or -45
degree diagonals in 2-D.
Where are the 11 synteny
blocks between human and mouse that we
have been considering in this lecture?
Well if you project these 11 blocks in 2D
to x-axis,
you will get the arrangement of human
synteny blocks.
And if you project it to y-axis, then
you will get the arrangement of mouse
synteny blocks.
Moreover, since we are not particularly
interested
in the scale of these blocks, and even if some
blocks appear
small, there are maybe hundreds of genes
in each of the blocks.
It's just an issue of scale.
So let us now represent each block by the
diagonal of the same size.
And once again, if we project these blocks
into 2D to the
x axis, we will get an arrangement of synteny
blocks in Phillip, and if
we project it to y-axis, we will get the
arrangement of synteny blocks in mouse.
And now, after we constructed synteny
blocks for two
genomes, How about constructing synteny
blocks for three genomes?
You can think about generalizing how
a synteny block construction approach for
more
than two genomes, but what about
constructing synteny blocks for 100
genomes that
are being sequenced now?
This actually turns out to be a very
difficult problem.
And nobody in the world today is able to
construct synteny blocks for 100 genomes.
Maybe after this course you will suggest a
reasonable approach for this.
But an interesting thing is that
if we learn how
to construct synteny blocks for many
genomes, we will
be able to come up with a very
accurate picture of chromosomal
organization in our distant ancestor.
So there is lot of work
ahead in developing genome rearrangement
and synteny
block construction algorithms, but this is
already beyond the scope of this course.